This episode is sponsored by groaned news. Judge, the truth for yourself
grow news is the world's first news comparison platform.
It will let you see how various media have processed information and alert you
to their political point of view.
This allows you to have a better awareness of what you are reading via a
political spectrum tool.
See the news that you're not seeing ground news is geographic filters.
Let you search everything from hyper-local news to global events.
And with all the news stories, breaking up a current events.
These days you'll be able to find accurate statistics and reliable facts.
News changes quickly, and the cycles are shorter than ever,
but at ground you can keep track of all the threads concerning your topics of
interest, refresh your memory on stories,
or just observe the way the news spirals out. You can also audit your own news.
Yeah, that's right.
They give you a sample of view of who has covered a story and where each outlet
falls on the political spectrum.
You can get the grind news up for free and both the Apple app store and on the
Google play store,
click the link in the description below and try and grind news for free. Uh,
now that's out of the way let's get into today's video.
[Inaudible].
So my friends are visual politic.
When we think of war surely the first images that come to mind for most of us
are of tanks, missiles,
and soldiers with huge automatic weapons and the middle of a battlefield.
Am I wrong? Because I bet I'm not. However,
the truth is that lately things are changing and changing a lot.
This type of war let's call it.
Traditional warfare looks to be in danger of extinction.
At least as far as the superpowers are concerned.
[Inaudible].
You see the countries that have historically be most active in the military
field,
such as the United States or Russia are less and less involved in sending huge
contingents abroad to defend their interests. Why? Well,
because this type of operation not only involves an enormous financial cost in
terms of weapons, transport, and all kinds of logistics,
but also has a high cost in terms of human lives,
a factor that is becoming increasingly difficult to,
to exempt because say during world war II or the Korean or Vietnam Wars,
the lives of soldiers were perceived as how should I put this less valuable than
the final objective over time, however,
political and social sensitivity to the massive human cost of war has changed.
And in fact, we can probably say that the Iraq war and the war on terrorism,
where the real.
Turning points.
This video,
we are going to talk about what the near future of war modern warfare might be.
We're talking about special operations.
No.
What on earth is that? And what do we mean by all this special operations stuff?
Well,
let's just say these are those clinical military operations whose objective for
example, is to strengthen or weaken an insurgent movement,
perhaps to bring political and social chaos to an enemy country by attacking key
fingers or infrastructure,
or to intervene and guerrilla warfare and irregular all of this, of course,
depending on the interests of the power involved. For example,
if it is in the interest of the United States to strengthen a group hostile to
the regime of the Iranian Ayatollah is the best way to do so maybe to send a
command, a special forces command to support, equip, advise,
and train that group. And this type of operation,
the rule of the conventional army is merely one of support. For example,
if the special forces command has problems and its mission and has to be
assisted or evacuated to the conventional army would intervene at that point.
As long as the problem could not be solved with another special operations team.
But having said that,
which countries can play a relevant rule on a global scale and this increasingly
active field of special operations? Well,
surely there are several candidates on the list box, my friends and this video,
we're going to look at the capabilities of three of the major players in this
new kind of multilateral cold war that we seem to be starting to have to live
with. I'm talking of course about the United States, Russia and China.
So my friends could special operations and unconventional warfare be the future
of warfare and even political confrontation. Well, the find out.
Get cracking
the elite of elite. Let me.
I'll ask you a question. When you think of a military elite,
what is the first thing that comes to mind? But wait,
don't answer that just yet, because I'm almost 100% certain,
it's something very similar to what we're going to see next because yes,
special forces are an essence that small group of super equipped soldiers with
advanced weapons and Nate vision equipment, thermal cameras,
and lots of gadgets that we've all seen at one time or another on the bank,
or if like me, you play video games on lane, the small screen,
they're always the guys who shoot me in the back column running away.
So how does it really all work well to get to know them better?
Let's see what they look like. The United States, special forces commanders,
presumably the best in the field and the whole world
Modern us special forces.
As we know them were created during world war two later while the cold war was
still raging throughout the 1980s and nineties,
the United States employed such commands mainly under the direction of the CIA.
We are talking about commanders who carried out missions of all kinds from
training and supporting what we've become warlords in Afghanistan to fighting
Pablo Escobar's cocktail or the F a R C in Colombia. However,
in 2001 after nine 11,
there was a change in strategy and the special forces began to become
increasingly significant within the army. Hey,
is precisely in this area that the U S special operations command U S UConn
based in Tampa,
Florida is the body tasked with supervising and coordinating the different,
special operations bodies of the army air force Navy and Marine Corps. Today.
It is estimated that the United States has around 70,000 such units of which
about 13,000 are deployed around the world, mostly,
obviously in the middle East,
but also in places as disparate as Latvia and South Korea,
where they train South Korean special forces
And take notes, because if there are no about 70,000 units of this tape,
back in 2001, this figure was just under three.
That is to put it lightly a wild increase,
which is due to the fact that the Bush administration multiplied and
strengthened the special forces after nine 11,
because they became a key element in the war on terrorism.
This policy was later continued by the following two administrations,
both the Obama administration and the Trump administration.
This is how groups like the Navy seals or Delta force,
which I'm sure you've heard of even if,
only from the movies or from my enrage screaming into my microphone.
When I'm playing on lane have become fundamental pieces of us foreign policy.
Now, the question is, why exactly do they do well?
These units are employed primarily in the counter terrorism and counter
insurgency missions. For example,
us special forces have done the vast majority of their work fighting ISIS and
Iraq and against Al-Qaeda and Iran. And also in Afghanistan,
they've also trained Iraqi and Afghan forces to be able to operate effectively
on their own.
Their operations are not usually highlighted in the media and in many cases are
not even public knowledge, but without them,
the weakened state of many of these radical groups today would probably not be a
fact, but let's focus on a more concrete case.
I'm sure you all remember the elimination of a Sama bin Laden in Pakistan,
right? Those images went around the world,
A Navy seal command composed of two dozen units supported by CIA agents,
landed a helicopter near the house where thanks to intelligence work.
Ben Latin had finally been discovered. The operation was Swift,
a stealthy and organized assault,
neutralizing all defensive targets on ending at last with the iconic leader of
Al-Qaeda. This intervention was textbook. In fact,
if one had to define what the modus operandi of a special forces command is,
this operation would be the primary.
Exempted.
I don't think that this was the only one nor the most top to vote without going
beyond at the beginning of this year, at the beginning of 2020,
the United States carried out yet another disposal operation in Baghdad. Yes,
it seems like years ago. I'm sure you remember.
We are indeed.
He's talking about the assassination of Iranian general Kasseem stolen money,
which was actually carried out quite differently. For example,
instead of eliminating him by sending a command to physically engage in battle
against him and his gardens on this occasion, a drone was used.
But if you thought that the operation consisted of a simple drone attack,
you are very, very wrong. In this case.
Us special forces vehicle was following Solomanis convoy very closely before the
attack from the drone. Furthermore, the attack from the drone was successful.
Thanks to the communication between that treeline command and the air force,
which was controlling the aircraft. Are you surprised? Well,
wait and see what comes next.
Because as well as this type of surgical attack to eliminate heads of rebel
groups or key figures,
there are other of operations in which special forces are typically very
efficient. We are talking about much riskier operations in which Russia.
Yes,
Russia Putin's Russia has demonstrated an amazing and yet highly worrying
proficiency. Do you have any idea where this might be headed? Well,
let's push on and find out.
Just silent invasions.
That's it, it's something that's and one way or another,
we have already talked about on several occasions,
Russia has developed special forces whose main specialty is silent invasions.
We are talking about the dreaded Spetsnaz, which with its 3000 units,
occasionally metals in Eastern Europe to defend the Russian bears area of
influence.
We are talking about a type of invasion that occurs without anyone noticing it
at first with almost no destruction and without killing almost anyone that's as
long, of course, as they don't get in the way.
Do you want an example of what we are telling you though?
I'm sure you know exactly where we are going,
because we are talking about where else Crimea
Invasion of the Crimean peninsula in 2014 was from a military point of view,
practically a historical landmark. Think about it for just one moment,
capturing a territory,
almost the same size as Maryland with a little more than 2 million inhabitants
without firing a single shot is without a doubt, something impressive suddenly.
And without anyone being able to prevent it,
some mysterious soldiers without flags began to arrive and the Crimea to
well-equipped to be irregular forces or groups of rebels,
and who also appeared to have an elite military formation.
We are talking about the so-called little green men who appeared overnight and
took control of the key infrastructure in the Crimean region, the media,
all the headquarters of public administrations and short they rapidly took
control of all the relevant enclaves with practically no use.
A force.
Quite a different scenario from the Dawn bus. By the way, of course,
all this it must be said,
was done with the logistic and military intelligence support of the conventional
Russian army, which has a Naval base in Sevastopol. The capital of Crimea,
a base that you can see is important because it's the main base of the Russian
fleet and the black sea.
[Inaudible].
And this is something important to take into account.
According to information that later became known Putin spent weeks sending
reinforcements to Sebastopol reinforcements in the form of ground troops on
standby to act in case things got complicated. You see,
despite what we might think the truth is that the trend in recent years,
for those special bodies to not act in isolation as may have happened in the
seventies, eighties, and nineties,
but to act in coordination with conventional armed forces.
That's explains why today,
despite the fact that this new form of targeted warfare seems increasingly
prepared by the superpowers,
it is still necessary for them to expand their military bases and strategic
alliances throughout the world
Example.
I'm sure many of you will be aware of the enormous military and territorial
expungement,
but China is pursuing and the countries of Southeast Asia and the famous dispute
regarding the artificial islands of the South China sea. Well,
all of this may have at least in part, an explanation,
closely links to what we have just seen.
If you control the territory militarily,
you may be able to also control the States nearby.
Although the Chinese special forces are still in their infancy.
The truth is that they have been investing a lot of money and effort since the
1990s to bring the elite forces up to the level of the Americans and the
Russians, My friends.
Would you like to know a little bit more about what the future of the people's
liberation army could be? If you do.
Let's check out
three way, future.
Anything is clear after everything we have told you in this video is that today
the difference between having a good armed forces and an armed force that can be
decisive and influential on a global level lies and its special forces. Yes.
Okay. You can have lots of tanks,
impressive fighter bombers and fleets of frigates,
but which power is willing to use all that force at once.
Do we really need to declare all out war if we can act?
And another way is more discreet quicker and with infinitely less economic and
most importantly human costs. Well,
as precisely for all these reasons that the country that is currently making the
most effort to increase its capacity to act with special operations groups is
none other than the Chinese Tatum. China has built not one,
but several special operations forces and facts,
each defense group into which the army is divided as its own elite unit.
And in this case, unlike the United States and Russia,
there is no single command at the moment,
but do you want some concrete examples? If you do check.
This ain't.
The Navy has the giant long unit meaning sea dragon,
which was created in 2002 and among other missions recovered a cargo ship
hijacked by Somali pirates in the Gulf of Aden.
Another example of Chinese special forces as the least Shen unit,
which is part of the air force.
The curious thing about this paratrooper command is that it came to receive
training at the military Academy of the Boulevard and national guard of
Venezuela, a training that was intended to improve their ability to fight.
Into junk. Anyway.
Well,
one like best to list at least 15 different special forces units within the
Chinese people's liberation army.
Each of the forces specializing in a different area at present is not known how
many soldiers compromise these units,
but it is estimated to be between 7,000 and 14,000. Yes,
that does seem like a far cry from the 70,000 to trained and equipped units that
make up the U S Corps,
but also many more than the barely 3000 soldiers that U S handled at the
beginning of the century. In other words,
the difference is much less than we might think at first school
And my friends, if China manages to fully develop this new capacity,
we could be facing a new paradigm,
a scenario in which the three major superpowers would be able to intervene in
complex operations operations that could influence the future of many countries,
their internal politics that could remove and establish governments,
feed rebel groups, and a Marriott of other actions of all Kings.
But hold on one moment, if this type of intervention becomes widespread,
how far could it go with the governments of Russia and China have any scruples
about meddling in countries allied with the United States or even an advanced
democracies to fool conflicts of all kinds.
Could this end up triggering a clash between the great powers.
Take notes?
Because there are experts who even argue having tens and tens of thousands of
operatives prepared to act continuously.
And these types of covert operations could become a risk to international
security attain bomb of future conflicts on a massive scale,
undoubtedly as is always the case. New strategies typically bring benefits,
also risks that we cannot ignore. But having said that it is now over to you.
Do you believe that the indiscriminate use of special forces for missions abroad
as a beneficial opportunity, or is that a risk to global security?
And as we asked you at the beginning of this video,
do you think this could be the future of armed confrontation?
Leave your opinion down here and the comments. And if you like this video,
don't forget to hit the like button and subscribe to our channel.
So you don't miss any of the videos we've got coming up in the future.
If you like this type of thing, you can also check out my podcast,
which is called making Europe rents. Again,
it's available wherever you get your podcasts. And finally,
a big thanks to green news,
the app that helps you see where your news is coming from.
Check out the free grind news up by following the link down below,
and as always.
See you next time.